the hat the way she wanted so
she was just upset that she i couldn't
be the girl the daughter where
in the past i let her do what she wanted
you know me to do like dress me up
uh be the doll get compliments from
others like how great she's well put
together because now she can't do that
and i think because she's also aging
she's she was so upset
yeah i mean it's
in five four three
two
one hello everybody welcome to another
episode of the genius brain podcast i am
your host david so and we have a very
special guest we have
mariel song
you know what the funny thing is i
actually downloaded an app to teach me
japanese i've been doing it every day
the weird thing is i didn't realize how
much japanese i know
because you know what the first like 30
lessons i breezed right through it in a
day i'm like oh wait i know all these
words i just don't i can understand it i
just don't know when to speak it
so it was throwing me off i'm like okay
next because you know at the end of
every lesson you have a test and it was
100 100 100 100 i'm like oh i understand
this but i can't speak it so i have to
go back and start applying the the
speaking part you gotta practice that's
why you have me
come on now i do it every day with you
you're gonna asian mom me that's what
i'm scared of speaking of asian moms
dude this this weekend was so
funny huh here's the thing guys
so since mariel and i have been together
right like
i'm pretty sure everybody knows that
when you're in a relationship especially
if you're you know engaged or you're
married or whatever
there's this period of like awkwardness
between
like whether it's the son or the
daughter or whatever uh when when you
kind of get together with in-laws right
and i could tell things are getting a
little more comfortable between us
because now her mom like shits on her in
front of me so that was your first time
experiencing that was my first time
she's never done that in front of me
before like she'll do that to the site
or she'll wait after and talk to you
about it on the phone yeah i was like
for you it was a bad experience for me
it was like i'm family
no
the funny thing was so here's the here's
the funny thing like her dad was in a
great mood i know he was and so
it was literally a sitcom moment because
after we had this dinner she'll explain
what happened uh after but it was that
moment where the two men start to bond a
little more because the wives are crazy
you know the wives or the wife
so like there was this book excuse me
i'm not part of that but i remember when
i was in the car and i was trying to ask
mariel in my mind what was going on and
how she was feeling i was like i better
word
phrase my words very carefully so i
don't get wrath
you know because her dad didn't phrase
his words carefully and then he got the
full brunt of the wrath and the funny
thing was right when we were in the car
i told mariel i was like your dad is in
trouble because i know when a man is in
trouble i was like
he should be quiet because he's going to
get wrath and i knew because she did
this thing that i think a lot of women
do it's like when they don't want to
make a scene they'll do this evil smile
they'll do this thing where it's like oh
okay
okay
your mom did that laugh and i was like
oh your dad's dead
oh it's like you're dead i'm like you
should stop talking don't do this
anymore because he was trying to lighten
the mood and make jokes but your mom
didn't want any of that no and i'm like
just
pops just stop
you're going down i wanted someone to be
on her side but
realistically everybody was
not i can't say it's on my side but they
were just being
rational and my dad was just you know
enjoying the time he was having a great
time and he was just being realistic so
explain to them what happened exactly my
mom has a thing about
hats
she loves hats
incredibly
loves hats and another thing that she
loves to do
ever since i was a kid is for me to wear
a hat
every time we go out
hat is required so
basically i'm an only child and i'm a
pretty tomboy girl my mom on the other
hand is a very very
the most girly girl you could ever
imagine and i'll put it to you like this
i've seen her for seven years i don't
know what the top of her head looks like
because she always wears a hat she's
very well put together for herself she's
like a walking human doll it's a it's
actually really adorable
and i think she has his
uh desire that her daughter will be
similar to her if not
a copy version of her so she always
tries to dress me up and has his like
ideal daughter where she could shop
together like you know
wearing the same hats and outfits i
guess
basically be mini her but unfortunately
i have my dad's jeans where i'm very
tomboy and very minimal um and i just
don't wear a lot of hats
unless i need it
and so and by the way when we say hat
we're not talking about like the cap on
her head i'm talking about like the
sunday church hat you know what i'm
saying yes like like wide brimmed
top hat type of thing
yes a fancy hat
and here's the thing
we were just done swimming
and i didn't have any makeup on i just
had a very casual outfit i didn't expect
to wear a hat that day
and so
it already started off wrong for her
because i am not looking like the doll
that she wants me to
and so she's like can you please at
least wear this hat i was kind of upset
already from there because i know what
that meant
and so
i still did i mean i had to say what i
had to say but i still did and
at the
at the dinner
how she
compared
i don't want to say that part actually
but basically uh she
was still
uh
it didn't meet her satisfaction that
i just wasn't wearing the hat the way
she wanted so
she was just upset that she i couldn't
be the girl the daughter where
in the past i let her do what she wanted
you know me to do like dress me up
uh be the doll get compliments from
others like how great she's well put
together because now she can't do that
and i think because she's also aging
she's she was so upset
yeah i mean it's a very weird thing to
watch right and i'm pretty sure a lot of
people who have parents who are a little
overbearing they they kind of look at
their kids as if they're always their
kids no matter how old they get right
yeah your mom definitely is on the a
little bit of the extreme side because
in her in her opinion she goes listen i
only see you every now and then right
how come you can't just do what i tell
you to do right yeah which
okay
logically i guess for me i'm like i
guess that kind of makes sense however
the problem with that and i think for a
lot of maybe this is like an
asian-american parent thing or an asian
parent thing it could be other cultures
too i don't know what to compare to but
it's almost like
you want me to be your object for a day
if you put it like that does it sound
great it doesn't sound very good right
and for for her like i was talking to
your dad right because so she she [ __ ]
up twice apparently because when we were
when we were swimming she asked her mom
to bring her blow dryer well we forgot
we brought it with us back to our place
and she needed her blow dryer for for
sunday because it's church and so she
was super super pissed so i i drove over
there to drop off the blow dryer she
wears a hat at the end yeah she still
wears a hat i don't understand what's
going on but normal so i had a
conversation with your dad and your dad
was kind of explaining to me
what what what happened and it was just
like
i i think for me when i see that right
it's it's a little bit of both things
right because i talked to my mom about
it too and i asked my mom like what do
you think
and she said that well no matter what
as a as a parent the kid is always their
child and they're only going back to
this moment from when they were a little
kid yeah right and the thing that threw
me off that was so blatant of your mom
which i actually appreciated the honesty
it was just the honesty wasn't great
because she said that i remember when
you were a kid and i used to take you
out and people used to compliment me
about how great you looked i was like oh
this is about
not you your daughter it's because you
missed the compliments that you got when
you used she used to dress you up as
this little cute girl because when
you're a little girl and you're dressed
up in this cute little dress absolutely
everybody thinks it's adorable but your
mom still wants to dress you up like
that cute little girl
but i ain't the little cute girl i'm an
older lady if not an old woman now
yeah why do you feel like it's so hard
for you to put on the hat here's
it's not hard because i did put the hat
on i know but you put on the hat i mean
this is just me giving you a second
thought it's like you put on the hat
after fighting with her about it you
didn't yes because when she put when she
asked you to put on the hat how come you
didn't just put on the hat and say okay
and then leave
i almost have this trauma now it's like
an immediate reflection
or yes immediate reflection of me just
automatically saying no because i'm so
tired of it
here's the thing
i
was a good girl so she told me to do
something i would do it and
i guess in that
and i thought i was doing the right
thing which i think in some way it is
but another way it didn't
help me develop boundary between her
decision and my decision
and so if she wanted me to do something
on like for not for me but like about
something to change about me i would do
it because it made her happy
but
now i have an opinion and i have my own
you know
opinion of how i want to
be shown to be displayed
and
me saying no is like a huge impact on
her now because i didn't create that
boundary
when i when when i was younger
so
now it's upsetting her because she
thinks i'm disrespecting
her requests yeah yeah yeah yeah you
know what i mean that was that was the
hard thing for me to connect right it
was when she was saying she couldn't
wrap her head around the fact that you
had this option to say no
right which to me was like oh i mean for
me it's a little extreme right it's like
every person has the option to say no to
the things that you request you don't
have to say yes
like in what world does anybody have
like unless this is a dictatorship and
you have to and you're going to die
i don't understand i guess that was the
hard part for me to kind of wrap my head
around because when when we were walking
into the restaurant she's like can you
get her just to say yes to me all the
time and i'm like
i'm like i don't think that's possible
like i don't think that's the thing can
you say can you just say yes all the
time when we meet up
prior to
that dinner we
i don't remember the last time we went
out for dinner because of covet so we
ate at home a lot yeah we did a lot of
takeouts so therefore we didn't have to
wear hats but can you imagine if covet
wasn't there and we met up every time
asking me to wear a hat well i remember
when we first met when we first started
dating and you were meeting up your mom
you wore a hat you wore make you did
your makeup you did everything yes like
you had jewelry on i'm like what the
hell is this and it was because you're
meeting up your mom yes there is a
requirement to meet up with my mom
and especially for going out which i am
fine to do i do it but we just came out
of swimming so
you know
the fact that she asked me to put that
hot hat on it meant something it meant
she was
commenting something about my look
commenting something about
you know how it would visually look it
how other people would think of me
that's the hard thing about being in a
korean community uh also a whole big
yeah especially like a korean church
community too because a lot of the
actions that we do we think about it in
terms of how it represents us all the
time right which to a certain extent
it's good right because now we're
thinking about community and i actually
like that about korean culture a lot but
there's a point where it becomes very
toxic where now every move that you make
is based on what you think somebody else
is going to say about your family about
how you present yourself when in reality
it's like is that really a way to live
there's a there's a fine line between
like
excessive and too much excessive and
then just the right amount right and i
think that for
you know for my personal experience as a
korean american
going to korean churches
like we've seen it like we've seen
parents go oh we're going to the
restaurant that person right there goes
to our church make sure that you kind of
present yourself right if not they're
going to say something yeah and i
totally understand that i totally
understand if you're in that community
and you want to be in that community you
kind of need to bend and you know i mean
they talk a lot of [ __ ] yeah you don't
want to deal with that drama yeah so you
do your best to eliminate those and i
totally understand that and my mom was
and i guess still is in that community
totally understandable but the question
comes down to like
is your
priority that
the society
you make the society more positive or
like me
then i i guess it's just like are you
thinking what do you feel do you feel
that she takes precedence over other
people's happiness versus yours i don't
know if it's a happiness but it's the
compliment mm-hmm i mean like i don't
know if they're happy
seeing me like wearing a hat you know
but it's the compliment that comes with
it the opinion that comes with it i
think that
sometimes is more of a priority than how
i feel yeah because the way she worded
it made it seem like she misses the
times where she used to receive the
compliment versus she misses the times
when you used to quote-unquote present
yourself more whatever the word is
ladylike or presentable in her eyes
right because one thing i do want to
clarify it's not like muriel is against
like when her mom wants to do the
classic k drama
you know mother or daughter thing where
they're like
i don't think marielle has anything
against that right i think the problem
comes is where like she doesn't get to
show her identity in it right so if
mariel goes out and she dresses in this
pretty dress she does her makeup a
certain way and she comes out and her
mom says
this doesn't look good on you though you
need to wear it like this and that's
where that issue comes in it's like
listen i'm okay doing the stuff that
honestly like would make you happy and i
would probably enjoy too
but
the boundary isn't there where she does
where she tends to like
i think hurt your feelings you know with
the things that she says
before we continue my lovely genius
farts thank you for keeping this podcast
sponsored and going click on the links
of our sponsors and check out their
stuff because this podcast is brought to
you by purple my friends purple mattress
the best mattress ever the mattress i
dream of every day because it helps me
sleep every night whenever i am
traveling all i do is think about my
lovely lovely
mattress not my wife she's on the you
know second tier list i guess just
kidding i love you very much don't
listen to this my dear because um yeah i
love my purple mattress very very much
sorry the gel flex grid is amazingly
supportive for your back and legs while
cushioning your shoulders neck and hips
no matter how you sleep if you have been
sleeping on a spring mattress or any
other mattress guess what you've been
sleeping on a bag of [ __ ]
get a purple mattress be like me it is
worth it we spend so much time sleeping
why do you spend your money elsewhere
get a purple mattress getting a great
night's sleep starts with having a great
mattress getty purple mattress go to
purple.com
brain 10. use code brain10 for a limited
time you can get 10 off any order of 200
or more that's purple.com brain 10 code
brain 10 for 10 percent off in the order
of 200 or more purple.com brain 10 promo
code brain 10 terms apply
so yeah like by the way mario's mom is
super [ __ ] sweet like her mom has the
best intentions for everything like i
make jokes about how she she literally
grabs my head and prays for me you know
what i mean and as weird as that is
that's a lot of great intentions she she
she worries for me and she cares for me
you know and i think that's like the
best quality about mario's mom is like
how much she cares sometimes though it
becomes a problem when how much she
cares and the things that she wants
overrides what other people want you
know there's no fine medium and so for
you when i see that i see like a lot of
um
a lot of what i had with my dad when i
was younger right but once again like in
this asian family dynamic boys get away
with a lot more things than um
than girls do and i think maybe just in
families in general yeah i think this if
i think about it this is very very
integrated to asian culture of
if i was the appropriate asian daughter
i would never reject her request
if you think about it if you see like
people like my friends and family in
korea when
visitors come or request has been made
they make sure
it happens even our friends within among
our friends asian american friends
because they have asian
parents
when certain things come around they
find it like you know it's not
appropriate or if it's not
you know
not something that they agree upon they
still accept it and move on with it or
you know
make sure that they're happy
because
it's embedded in their asian culture
you know what i mean like they'll be
they will be like saying like oh i want
to do this i want to do that i want to
do this and then it could be very
inconsiderate in one way but at the same
time because they are your a your
parents in asian culture you wouldn't
um
you wouldn't reject their request
you would make sure like okay i'll do
whatever i can to help you parents
because i'm your kid
there's no like oh you do it your way
i'll do it my way there's like none of
those kind of conversations yeah
and i think because i'm more
american
so when she sees that
and i'm sure
she compares with her other you know
friends kids and whatnot like see that
i'm not
accepting or quote-unquote respecting
her requests she feels like
she's being disrespected
but that's the weird thing too because
when i had issues with my dad one of the
things that my dad had to come to terms
with was the fact that and this is what
my mom was there for right my mom albeit
we do still argue we still fight but a
majority of our conversations are great
she was the person that had a champion
me like she had to
get my dad to understand like listen you
decided to come to the states we didn't
have to come here right you wanted this
life you thought that it was better for
us well guess what you raised a kid in
america but you're expecting him not to
be an american kid and i did that
doesn't make sense you know like the
that that's not fair right you got to
let him live the life that he wants to
live and if you wanted him to grow up
with those ideals we should have stayed
in korea
right a lot of second generation
have the same feeling
that
they can't figure out how to be fully
american nor fully asian because
sometimes when we're outside we feel
like we're very asian and when the
household feel very american and neither
of them
are accepting who we are
and honestly like i you know i give
kudos to my parents because they work
really hard to where they are i mean
clearly they didn't like
foresee this happening in their life
thinking that oh there's going to be a
huge culture clash blah blah is just
like they're thinking the positive side
it's like we're going to have a better
life here etc etc so their intention is
good and
i have huge respect for my mother
because she's a business woman she came
here with no degree
learning english on her own
and able to get a phd degree on her own
and still studying till this day having
her own business and doing really well
for her
and if if there's
if someone asks me who's my idol when it
comes to or like a role model when it
comes to
you know career it's my mom because
she was able to do everything by herself
i wouldn't say dad my dad doesn't speak
english so my mom had to take care of
the legal contracts you know real estate
everything on her own and i think for
someone who
came to a country didn't understand the
language and had to learn on her own and
able to
have a successful career
is
amazing so
that said
and she knows she knows that she could
speak english really well even though
she always says she can't like she her
english is great yeah if she could run
her own business by herself yeah her
english let's put it like this her
english is better than my korean
like she uses complicated english words
that i wouldn't be able to use
conversely and all her clients are not
even korean too yeah so her english is
perfectly fine she's just a little uh
shy about it yeah but when i hear her
speak english i'm like your english is
[ __ ] great yeah i could talk to her
english perfectly fine she understands
everything but that said
i can't blame her when she says that
you're not korean enough because
she
it's not like her intention was that i
you know she's gonna have a baby here
and the baby's gonna be so american that
she that she won't understand me like i
grew up
learning korean that was my first
language i grew up with my grandma so i
am very immersed with korean culture as
you know like when i go to korea like i
could adapt very easily yes i am still
like i still stand out as a korean
american but
at least i could get around without a
problem
but
nonetheless even though i tried that
hard where i lived in korea
and try to like be as korean as i can be
i can't be
in the korean culture that my mom once
lived because if we when we went to
korea it was so different the culture
has changed those koreans have changed
so much that their mom didn't really
understand and i think even my mom
doesn't understand right is that
what their version of what korea is
now is different it's so different like
and i'm talking about this is one of
these like i'd say this is like my
korean like pride coming in in terms of
how different korea is and this is
within 20 years right i'm talking about
20 years ago and
so before when i was 14 years old and
that was the last time i was in korea
we had to go with a lot of gifts
and by gifts i mean stuff that honestly
over here is just next to nothing
one of the things that everybody brought
shampoo conditioner centrum
the vitamin centrum neosporin
was like medicinal stuff and the reason
why was like 20 years ago in korea a lot
of the stuff that they had to get was
from they said was from china and there
was no um qc like quality control yeah
and so they didn't know what was good or
bad people were getting like [ __ ] up
by a lot of these products so before we
went to korea we had to bring stuff that
they knew was good quality which was
american stuff because the standards
were really really good and now when we
went to korea this time mind you it's
been 20 years for me i go there there's
oh they don't need [ __ ] they have
literally everything and better yeah
more and more yeah and then some so
and i bring this up because meryl's
mom's trying to be really sweet and she
wants uh marielle to be taken care of so
she wants marielle to bring all of the
relatives a lot of gifts but the gifts
that she was asking us to bring was in
my mind i'm like i'm pretty sure they
have this stuff there which was like
peanuts like nuts you know what i mean
they still like that i mean they still
like that they still loved it but
literally the first day that we're there
we see a lady selling peanuts like fresh
roasted on the side of the road and the
market had all kinds of everything we're
talking abouts we're talking pine nuts
walnuts
nuts galore
they didn't have avocado yeah they have
a cup
all this other stuff that we think is
you know privy to like the american
lifestyle korea has it and then some
right so when i saw that i'm like oh
her version of what she thinks korea is
is not what it used to be right and
albeit 30 years ago
this was very very true yeah you know
korea went through this hardcore like
second wave industrial revolution in
terms of like import export whatever the
[ __ ] that it is that allowed korea to be
as great as it is now when i went there
this past time i was amazed you know
even like within 10 years
everyone in k-town we're telling or even
our friends we're telling how k-town
food is so much better than korea
because of the meat and the vegetables
that we have yeah we went to korea this
round how was it it was literally the
best korean food i've ever had in my
life there was nothing like what do you
mean the meat was great the vet there
the beef was amazing yeah
every and it was not to mention very
cheap yeah and so for them when they
said that it was probably true because
10 years ago they went there and we went
there now i was like um this food is
substantially better than the [ __ ] that
i've had in l.a yeah
it doesn't even compare even the side
dishes oh yeah that's the crazy thing so
when you guys like come to k-town or
whatever cape town that you go to i feel
that
when it comes to the panchan right
that's uh side dishes in korean
um those things are just there to kind
of like pick at as you eat your other
food there's not a lot of like attention
and care put into it when we went to
these korean restaurants the the
attention in carrot was in every single
dish that came out whether it was the
panchan whatever the hell that it was
it was very very well cared for and
presented very well and it tasted like
it was all homemade it wasn't made from
a factory like it was a mass production
it felt like they made it in the kitchen
yeah it was it was really really really
good i was so surprised at
well i guess it was a good thing people
kind of said that because my
expectations were a lot lower and then
when i went there i'm like this is some
of this is the best korean food i've had
outside of my mom's food so that's i
mean even if if we're talking about 10
years within 10 years that much has
changed crazy 20 years is insane like
they did back in maybe in the 90s i
don't even know if banana was around
like that's oh dude that banana story
was crazy dude so like i i guess in
general like her aunts were telling us
like how much koreans like coveted
bananas yeah because banana they didn't
have banana in korea because it didn't
grow first of all and there was an
import of um bananas so they weren't
allowed to import it was it there wasn't
yeah yeah cause remember she was telling
the story of how she brought the banana
in so my grandma
this is like in the 90s or 80s or
something i think it was in the 80s um
she was here in the u.s and she knew how
much banana was so precious to koreans
that's why there is even a song
um that has
it
i forget what the song i forget how it
goes but there is a song where a banana
is involved where they say if it's a
good food it's banana
but that's it so she
went to the airport had a box of banana
and clearly you can't bring produce
to the airport because you can't fly
with them um but back then it was just
you know it wasn't as strict as it is
right now so i think my grandma really
complained and also begged the people
that hey my kids want bananas let me
take some of the bananas so she actually
was able to take the banana to korea but
that's how
limited
resource they had back then
it's crazy like when i hear those
stories i'm like that's why banana juice
is such a huge thing or banana milk yeah
like i remember when i was there when i
was uh 14 2 like it was banana
everything yeah it was like banana
flavored everything i'm like what the
[ __ ] is with this banana [ __ ] i hated it
i hated it so much it's it's all
nostalgic
yeah yeah yeah i mean so it's like you
know just to go back to that
conversation like there there is a lot
of empathy when it comes to just our
parents and like you know mario's mom
and even my mom yeah like we got into a
fat argument because she didn't
understand what the [ __ ] i was saying i
was telling like korea's not the korea
that you grew up in oh yeah you know
yeah it's not the same thing
you know yeah it's it's
you know there's no hard feeling like i
wish you know i'm sure some people if
they're listening to they'd be like why
can't you just wear the hat which i did
wear the hat by the way but there was a
little bit of friction back and forth
because
there's a whole history to it is that
well you know for me too
it's also the idea
that it's just
do as i say because i say so and to me
whether you're a
i mean when you're a child you're you
know kids don't know very much and
they're not you know they're not fully
autonomous in the sense that a lot of
their choices
are not going to be the best because
they're young and they don't have life
experience yeah but you're in your 30s
you know and so when somebody who you
are an adult and another adult tells you
do as i say so it's a little
disrespectful you know as a person you
know because even though she feels
disrespected i think if she took a step
back and says if anybody said to you do
as i say so
would you be happy yeah right you know
and the idea is is that when you say
that you're basically saying that i'm in
control of you i own you yeah and
because i own you you do as i say and
when you don't do that
i feel very disrespected
this podcast is sponsored by better help
my lovely genius farts you know how much
i love my better help you know how much
i love mental clarity you know how much
i love therapy because i've been using
it my whole life and better help just
makes it so much easier so accessible
and so affordable i can't get enough of
it baby
you know me
i'm all about mental health if you are
focusing on your physical health why not
worry and work on your mental health my
friends because i know some of you out
there feel helpless in a little trap and
you might even feel that little bit of
fatigue but you can't figure out why
well guess what it could probably be
associated with burnout it could be
associated with the fact that you are
not prioritizing your mental health well
guess what my friends better help is
customized online therapy that offers
video phone and even live chat sessions
with your therapist so you don't have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy and you can be matched
with the therapist in under 48 hours
genius brain listeners get 10 off their
first month at betterhelp.com
genius that's better help dot com slash
genius
there's no disrespect in a person who is
an autonomous being to say hey
i don't think i want to especially
because it's just a hat
because if if the idea is that it's just
a hat why can't you wear it the same
goes for the other way around if it's
just a hat how come i can't choose not
to wear it when it makes me
uncomfortable yeah and not to mention i
do wear hats and she didn't wear the hat
she didn't wear the hat by the way i did
wear the hat but other times too when
we're out and about i do
dress up the way that she likes so that
she is pleased i i do that it's just i
wasn't the day then the hard part is too
and you know for a lot of people out
there who are kind of you know coming
into their full adult form right where
they are like these independent beings
you know i've told this to muriel years
ago and obviously she you know she
talked with her therapist and obviously
coming from you know your significant
other somebody's close to you it comes
off as nagging but we talked about
boundaries you know and i think the way
i expressed it i didn't think you really
understood it obviously because the way
i explained it probably wasn't it was so
harsh you know because
i understood boundaries from a long time
ago and what i mean by that is that
though from the outside it may seem like
oh just wear the hat
right but to her point what happened
when she wore that hat
the hat was just the starting point yeah
it didn't matter she wore the hat yeah
it was something else and then it's
something else and this is what we mean
by boundaries and we have to be able to
recognize hey
is this just about the hat or is this
just something bigger thing and the
bigger thing was
when i when you were younger you did
exactly what i told you and when i told
you what to do it made me happy and so
that's the overarching thing that's
happening here it's not just wear the
hat it's if i wear this hat what else
does this lead to and it did lead to
something else because when you wore it
it didn't end it did not end it went
through the whole dinner for me it was
quite entertaining because watching your
dad just burn
in front of my in my eyes was hilarious
and i had no idea what was coming
because her dad was trying to be funny
he was trying to make jokes and i'm like
bro this is not the time
like you need i couldn't tell him to
stop
i just wanted him to stop i'm like
you're gonna be in so much trouble i saw
the laugh i saw the okay and you know
what that laugh is everybody knows what
that laugh is you [ __ ] just wait
just wait till we get home
and i saw it and literally i told her in
the car i said hey your dad's in big
trouble watch and then what happens he
called her the next day he goes oh my
god i got ripped apart last night i was
like i knew that was going to happen
yeah i mean he was on my side what can
you say nobody was on her side
i know i messed up a little bit too even
you you weren't on her side well when i
said that i was like i [ __ ] up it's i
mean it's fine the main target is me so
i mean she was she i think that night
she just wanted to be right and then
nobody was giving it to her so it made
her feel like oh everybody's against me
you know um and i understand that i
i mean i guess in in a way to make the
night lighter i could have just
let her do what she wanted to do
but then again that comes to the whole
therapy conversation of making your own
boundaries i just don't i think if you
did that it still wouldn't have ended so
i i think in that case um
i don't think just wearing that hat
would have been enough i think if there
is a dinner plan to go out i'm gonna be
like let me bring a whole outfit top to
bottom
yeah so you know so then
it's a it's a complete set for her so
there's then we could just have a good
dinner yeah and i know that it's just we
just went swimming so i couldn't prepare
for that and i didn't expect that to
happen i didn't expect it either it was
a little shocking it it was so come to
my life david so so mario's mom said
something at the dinner table which i
disagreed with and i wasn't like like
disagreeing in the terms of like oh no
no i'm like oh no no i don't think
that's the case and when i said that she
did the smile again and i was like oh
[ __ ]
i'm on her backside dude so when i came
to drop off the hairdryer she'd even
come downstairs you know what her mom
was doing her mom was praying for her
soul
she was praying for mariel's soul
asking god to like hey some my daughter
needs to just be a better person like
usually her mom will come down and say
hi to me and i'm like it's cause i
[ __ ] up yesterday she didn't like
anybody in that table i know she she
gave me the smile i was like oh i'm dead
too
i was like oh [ __ ]
i should have just said like oh probably
but i just i just disagreed
it was so old now you know now you know
you're in the family now you're on the
same boat as me and my dad
i know man it was so interesting there
was a really good bonding moment for me
and your dad though i was like oh [ __ ]
because i remember in the car too i i
wanted to ask muriel i'm like how come
you couldn't just wear the hat but if i
said that it would have just been a not
a good thing so i was like the car was
like how do i phrase this how did you
phrase it huh i said
i said something along the lines of like
oh i was like
uh what is the reason that you're
against wearing
the hat yes you did i know i remember
how you phrased it i was in the car just
thinking calculating i'm like phrases
correctly i just thought what happened
to her father
you phrased it actually very nicely
where i could explain it
yeah and i it made sense too like it
made it i appreciate that so much
because if he just came up like what can
i just wear the hat
i just don't want this you really want
to have this conversation dude you know
at the dinner table i love telling the
story because this [ __ ] was so [ __ ]
funny so when mario and i first started
dating right and i think as a guy um
i've i've always been taught to pick up
the bill
right and then mario 2 by the way she's
very good at picking up the bill
especially when we first started dating
she was an intern and she wasn't making
a lot of money and so now that she has a
stable job now we like either dutch pay
or you know well not so much dutch pay
she'll pay i'll pay she'll pay i'll pay
right so one time we were going out to
eat and this [ __ ] lightweight got on my
nerves a little bit because she's
like
no it's not i was legit
okay no she was not go okay so literally
the bill comes out right she goes don't
worry i got this one i'm like okay cool
i'm watching this girl go through
molasses trying to find this card i've
never seen somebody move so slow in my
life to pick up a bill she's just like
okay this is the card by the way let me
just show you okay
this is her cards right this is her
going into her purse
i wonder where my card is
i'm sitting here watching this by the
time she finds her card i already gave
my card they came back with the business
oh my god
such a liar i
was just i don't know why you say yo
so slowly
i've never seen somebody move so slow in
my life i thought you were moving at 120
frames per second i said i got it so if
i oh
all my time
as long as i got it that's all that
matters right i've never seen you search
for something so slow in my life and
you're a very fast paced person
look if you want me to pay for the bill
just say so you know what i could have
really paid it you don't have to go
through with this whole show
and did i papa got the bill papa papa
got the bill don't worry papa got it
okay everybody heard that papa pay the
bill 24 7 now i always do don't worry
about it i got it okay okay thank you
buddy worry about it thank you i got you
papa has the bill dude thank you papa
bye papa
i never call you papa she told me this
funny thing too uh today and this is the
first thing that has ever happened to
her oh my god this is so weird spill the
tea spill the tea so
she got unfollowed by one of her friends
and she doesn't know why
and this is the weird thing for me right
if i get unfollowed i know why i'm a
loudmouth guy i have a lot of weird
opinions i make a lot of jokes and
sometimes it runs people the wrong way
so if they unfollow me i get it i 100
understand why with you i don't get it
you're not very opinionated about
anything publicly you don't really post
anything too personal everything you do
is just like your art harmony stuff or
like stuff that we do in korea yeah and
it's not it's it's just like a regular
instagram here's the thing
i
99 of the time i can't say 100 anymore
don't check if a friend follows me or
not yeah i don't but some people yeah
why would we right because they're
friends so this friend i've been saying
to her every year happy birthday we keep
in touch i mean we kind of lost touch to
here and there because we have our own
separate lives but nothing went to the
baby shower everything yeah we went i
went to go see her baby everything was
fine
and i've been we've been chatting on
instagram
only to find out that she unfollowed me
some time ago like this is a friend too
by the way mariel has never said a
single bad thing about her yeah tell
this that i still talk about her right
yeah she like marielle mentioned like
how much her mom loves her like she's
such like this pretty korean girl like
you've never said anything bad about her
it's a korean girl yeah for sure and
to
i mean
the fact that she took the extra step to
unfollow me
she definitely
[Applause]
made it clear that we're not friends
it's it's very weird though i just don't
understand why though like
i wish i knew i don't know
because i do remember you telling me
that you were saying happy birthday to
her or whatever and then out of nowhere
it was just like unfollow here's the
weird thing about that usually when that
happens it's like zero connection at all
or there was like some type of event
yeah the thing that maybe kind of
bothers me about that is that you guys
were actually pretty close friends you
guys been friends for a very long time
and that has never happened to me with
any close person at all unless it was a
very cataclysmic event yeah i mean we
had our ups and downs but we made it
through
and
i don't know it's just
i think it's just very clear like how
she made up her mind but here's the
thing i've been thinking about this
because it was just kind of mind-blowing
i'm like wow what the hell happened like
yeah so
the thing is that
i
this is a vicious cycle for me and i
keep warning myself is that
any friendships that i make
in a short time
where we feel like we're so close and we
click so well oh i talked about this on
my phone we could talk about anything
is an alarming
alarming sign and also a flag for me
that i need to
step back it breaks yes and
i like to have it slow
pace
like i i kind of think of it as fire
like i like to have those thick wood
that last long time
burn long time if it's one of those fire
that just happens really fast big it'll
end really fast too
yeah and you know like i've i've
mentioned this before where i've i've
talked about this and you know i've used
a very crass way of talking about it
which is [ __ ] on the first date and i
say that a lot of girls do that though a
lot of girls do that thing where they go
oh my gosh we're best besties yeah and
that [ __ ] used to always piss me off
because i knew the end result and it's
not that anybody's
necessarily bad or good or whatever it's
that none of you know each other so you
don't even know if you're actually
really good friends you don't know if
you match well exactly when you get to
know somebody over time you get to make
the choice of that's a bad quality am i
okay with that
because nobody's perfect you know i have
[ __ ] ton of bad qualities that my best
friend deals with all the time you know
and he has annoying qualities that i
deal with all the time but i'm okay with
it because we've built this relationship
and this strong foundation over time the
foundation yeah never
is never made with those friendships so
it breaks through easily was she a fast
friend too
she was a fast friend
but
we also
had long time
being friends like keeping in touch
every night yeah keeping in touch so i
thought for sure that she wasn't one of
those friends
but
lord behold
i mean i mean it's all good i think it's
very weird that it happened that way
also it's very embarrassing for me to
say oh my gosh
so and so unfollow me because i never
say that that sounds so cheesy well it's
not the fact that it's cheesy it's more
like if it's like some random person
yeah it might be a little cheesy but
this isn't a random person you've known
for years
like for years almost a decade yeah yeah
almost a decade that's very very odd but
i don't know so i guess she is one of
them because yeah but it also kind of
makes her uh a coward though
that's a coward right there it's like
listen if you if i did something to
offend you or you have an issue then you
should talk to me about it instead of
this like subtle weird way of just like
not responding to birthday texts and all
this other stuff she did respond though
that's the thing she totally
responded to every message
was it very was just like oh thank you
listen yeah yeah yeah see that's what
i'm saying that's some coward [ __ ] like
what a [ __ ] like you little [ __ ] like
if you have a problem just say that you
have a problem and then we could hash it
out and say like oh i'm sorry or we
could be like oh maybe we shouldn't be
friends right well here's the thing the
fact that she didn't do it and she
decided on her own it's actually
kind of worse because she's saying oh
you're not worth to discuss and fix this
problem it's not that she's a coward she
doesn't she's she's not somebody who can
sit there and have a conversation with
you and defend what she has to say
right because those type of people if
you confronted them and said like hey if
i did something to offend you right and
clearly you unfollowed me i know this
sounds really childish but because you
and i have been friends for 10 years
when you unfollow me makes me feel like
i did something to hurt you what did i
do exactly you know what she'll do she
goes oh did i unfollow you i had no idea
i guarantee you that's what she'll do
especially when it comes to people who
are supposed to be friends that's why i
dislike it so much when people go like
oh that's my friend and i correct people
now and i go we friends i'm like okay i
guess no we know each other
right because i don't want people to
have the the wrong idea of what we are
right
because having the right expectations
also sets you up to be uh it sets up the
friendship to kind of grow
because yeah for now we might be
acquaintances but we could be friends
after a long time yeah like nick and i
were he was my coach
then nick became my coach and from my
coach he became an acquaintance and from
an acquaintance he became a friend and
now he's a really really good friend
yeah but that took what five years four
years that took a while
before i even let him in my house so
even at work before pandemic like i
would have a lot of co-workers i would
talk to a lot and so there could be like
bond that we make but that doesn't mean
we're friends so like you know i take my
time again with like co-workers anybody
if they're trying to like get close to
me real fast and be like oh my god
what's your instagram oh my god we need
to hang out x y and z i'm like the i'm
the polar opposite like i
you know people you don't need to do
that to connect with somebody no you can
have really good interactions and then
have another great interaction and then
another one and another one and then be
like hey like i want to get to know you
let's go get something to eat
right yeah like savannah who was my
pa
long long long time ago we you know we
were just like i like to keep things
professional we're not friends right um
at that time they weren't at that time
at that time and then i got to know her
as a person because i working with her
60 hours every week like you get to
really know people
and i really liked who she was she was
like there's a freaking hard working
lady who's trying to do her best and
she's always like two steps ahead i was
like i like this quality and then so
from there
you know we got to really bond and then
we left to other different studios kept
in touch and then
was able to hang out outside of work
knowing that hey
actually we connect it's not because of
this like
and it took a long time i think that was
like what five years in and then we
finally became friends yeah
and lord behold we're still friends like
we've gone through a lot of [ __ ] and
stuff but we're still friends and i
think it's because we know how we are
yeah you guys got to have like these
like it's like um when you train your
shins right you get micro fractures and
it becomes it comes back builds stronger
micro fractures builds stronger right
versus having a full-on clean break your
leg just snaps in half amen everybody
that's how you do it muay thai baby
let's go yeah that's like the calluses
when you're climbing you get your first
flap you're like fudge that hurts but
then it grows
how is your comparison any better than
mine what are you talking about i'm just
saying i'm going along with your analogy
yeah you know like everybody's it's just
there's in such a rush to make
connections and do things like how come
things you can't just slowly you know
what's so sad though like maybe it's not
sad but
i fall first so bad because i'm like i
really want that too
but then i'm like now i'm triggered i've
been triggered but
no but like listen it's it's not bad to
be like damn this person was really cool
it's just now you go damn that person
was really cool hey maybe next time we
should hang out a little bit but not go
like oh my god this person they're
exactly like me oh my god we think
exactly the same impossible i mean yeah
yeah impossible remember i told you that
story about my that only that i got to
know in korea and she just disappeared
on me yeah that's another great example
right we hung out every night we
literally hung out every night i even
got to see her family who lives in a
whole different county
that's how close we got and then out of
nowhere she went in miami like she
ghosted me until the day i had to leave
listen that's some cowardice [ __ ] i
don't know if you have an issue or you
have a problem then let's talk about it
if you say we are friends if not then
don't say we're friends and we'll just
keep it cool like that you know that's
just what i'm saying like
i'm i'm not um
i can at times be too straightforward
right yes i'm very very very she knows
this about me i'm very i'm
i am not a non-confrontational person no
i'm somebody who likes to put it out
there i've gotten a lot better now where
now i pick and choose when i do it and
what i don't right and the reason why is
because when i was younger i used to be
so scared it used to just things would
just blow up in my face all the [ __ ]
time when i was a kid i used to get my
ass beat for just like
doing white lies and so now because i'm
so hyper open is people get scared of
that stuff and i'm okay with that right
because the the the idea that my dad put
into me when i was younger was that you
know what
there are so many bad things can happen
when you're a dishonest and um conniving
human being
that if you hurt a few people's feelings
being an honest person at least you know
that you were right
you can live with that
you know so the only difference is that
my dad didn't teach me about tact
you know what lies you mean like white
lies are just tacked in general you know
like when i say things sometimes even
when i text people who i work with i go
[ __ ] i think i they're probably going to
misinterpret that even though i don't
mean anything bad by it right like so
i'll like for example i sent a
uh an email out where it was like hey
uh when you write things blah blah blah
blah are you telling me to correct this
because if it is is it a personal thing
that you want or is it something that's
within uh our company guidelines that i
should adhere to if it's something
personal you should probably keep that
to yourself and then we'll just keep it
professional
and so that sounds really harsh but i'm
not even mad at them i'm just like oh
look hey we'll just separate the stuff
out and i just at the end i was like if
that's okay with you let's continue
forward that let me know if you need
anything else and then in my mind i went
hmm that might be a little harsh
but i'm not i'm not angry though i'm
just like oh let's just separate my i'm
just saying matter of fact and i'm going
about my day and i stopped when
literally in the middle of the day i
went
i think i hurt their feelings
how did that come around because usually
that person responds back to emails a
lot faster
they're probably like oh [ __ ] so i wrote
back and i was like
hey you did a great job blah blah blah i
just want to know so i don't stress you
out yeah you know just making sure that
you're good right man emails the way the
communication is so
so hard i mean you know all these like
friendships that went down the hole for
me
i can't say it's like
i'm sure
half of the reason is because of me
i mean who knows man like i've had a lot
of friendships that went down the hole
you know and i'm just completely okay
with it there was somebody that gave me
the silent treatment for two years i
didn't even know
and they got mad when i found when they
found out that i didn't know that i was
i got the silent treatment and they got
mad again and they took me for another
two years that's so funny like legit
this person came up they're like so i'm
done giving you the silent treatment and
i'm like you gave me the silent
treatment
and they were like are you kidding me i
haven't talked to you like in two years
i was like i know it's been good
i was joking did it not take it very
well but i was like listen you gotta
understand like i don't know these
[ __ ] things i'm continuing with my
life
if you want to be upfront about
something then we can address it right
and i'll either apologize or we could
hash it out right because i'm not beyond
saying sorry to my friends if i [ __ ] up
right because we're friends i care about
your feelings to a certain extent yeah
so like i just don't like that type of
stuff and listen man like i've
one of the things that i can say that
i'm very proud of is that i have i you
know this i keep friends for a very long
time like
the friends that i've had i've had for
over 10 12 15 years yeah they're all
your childhoods all my childhood friends
i don't throw friendships away easy if i
threw you away it's because you did
something really real what if you guys
don't click anymore like there's nothing
still talking about decent friends
though we don't i don't cut them out
yeah you know like we meet up we'll have
drinks we hang out for an hour or two
here's the thing that friend who
unfriended me yeah i mean like honestly
like how often did she ever hit you up
did she ever ask how you were doing
congratulations and like like those type
of things too like
like me and me and gobble right like
that's he's not even my best friend
anymore he's like blood brother to me
like i'd kill for that guy right and
he's somebody who always calls on me he
checks up on me we talk on the phone for
like a couple of hours we catch up we
joke around whenever he's successful in
things like i'm always happy for him
he's always happy for my success and
that's the type of friendship i'm gonna
have forever like he's somebody that i
would [ __ ] kill for the same goes for
joe same thing goes for bart all these
people right
but once again what is the biggest
deciding factor of that time
that thing was time like gobble and i
became probably best friends after high
school
so and that was like three years of
friendship in high school and then we
started to realize i was i started to
realize like
that's my best friend
like he's he's somebody that will never
ever do me wrong at all and he'll take
my side
you know and even for him
like i've made ridiculous problems
ridiculous promises to him even like
stuff because i want to support him
right and that's that's the type of
stuff that i really really cherish
there's even somebody who had on this
podcast recently his name is tom we talk
to each other every now and then sell
them but i respect so much what he does
and just who he is in general and how
good of a person he is
um
he's somebody like if we have a wedding
i'd invite to my wedding even though we
don't talk that much but because we have
this mutual respect for each other i
cherish friendships like that too
you know
there are good amount of friends who i
barely see
i barely able to see them just because
of physical distance
that
i would totally if i think about it
right now like i would totally cherish
those friends more
than that person than that person who
lives in the same 100 like the person
that you met in korea um the person that
was your boss before that's somebody
when i saw you two interact i'm like
this is real friendship this is
friendship you guys pick up and you you
guys it didn't seem forced it didn't
seem anything it literally felt that you
guys talk to each other every day she's
a good example where
it took some time for us to get close
because she was my boss yeah
and she i think she was waiting to see
if like i would be a good candidate to
be her friend because i think she kept
everything professional
and then
i think
she saw that we could click
i think what i liked about her too she's
very like the way that she would speak
to you was very open and honest about
her feelings yeah nothing was really
reserved and you guys were just chatting
it up and it was just for me it was nice
to watch i was like oh that's a really
good relationship right there and those
are the type of relationships you want
to build when you would hang out with
her and the other friend the mutual
friend you guys seem like very surface
friends like oh my god
and i'm like
[Music]
you know what i mean i'm like yeah it is
very like that it's not like how you and
becky speak to each other oh hell no
like she her best friend her name is
becky and becky
when i see them too they look like
siblings the way they argue they fight
they bicker it's so obnoxious but i'm
like that's real friendship though she's
also your twin
that makes me really sad
i'm like timmy i picked a dude version
of my best friend
like but you guys have this like
chemistry
you know and like the way they hang out
they just sit they talk they chat they
come for meals casually like it's
nothing like
becky can walk into this house at any
time that she wants and i would not care
you wouldn't even notice and i wouldn't
even notice and she's like i'm taking a
nap i'm like cool whatever i brought
some food i'm like cool whatever you
know she's somebody that i really i'm
really glad that she's in your life you
know yeah and that's the type of vibe
that that lady in korea gave me i was
like oh you guys are like good good
friends
with this one though i can understand
where i didn't really see it it was more
like oh my god blah blah blah it was
still very service even 10 years have
passed you guys seem like very fun
friends very fun acquaintances yeah
yeah you know and
yeah it would be so funny and she's like
i really did follow you up by accident
unfollow you by accident then she hears
this and she starts crying
but it's like whatever whatever i mean i
told you know it's that's a good point
because i think about it i know more
about that on these family that you do
about her yeah yeah that's another great
sign right well guys
that was actually a very good podcast i
enjoyed that conversation very very much
look back and see your friends and see
if you really know them or not and then
question about it yeah set boundaries
with your parents dude and be you know
it's hard man it's it's always hard
doing that with people who are close to
you because it's uncomfortable but just
like anything in life like the
uncomfortable parts is where you grow um
i'm i mean we're i'm struggling with
that [ __ ] every day too it's not like
these answers that i give you is
something that i'm not trying to apply
in my life i have to apply it every
[ __ ] day and it's so uncomfortable
you know
um
but yeah guys
thank you guys for listening genius
brain podcast every sundays at 12 p.m
you could see mario at mario underscore
underscore song and also my harmony
story is where you could see her who she
should start working on her children's
book which i've been waiting for years
giving her a little pressure give her a
little pressure too she needs it and
it's in a really amazing story that you
guys will be able to listen to and i
think it'll be great so hopefully uh i
put it out there that you have to put it
out so you have to know okay okay okay
we'll see you guys next time thank you
bye